hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot and I'm standing outside the
doors of e3 2014 with a giant line of
people behind me now as I was looking
around the front of the line here I
noticed my friend from last year Eric
how are you doing it's fine thank you
and you are at the front of the line yet
again how many times have you been at
the front of the line for e3 all the
years but yeah for this one it's a bit
mmm i had a ghost english always really
i know at least i've been here every day
early yeah how early did you have to get
here what time were you here well that's
today I actually tied five but not
didn't manage to getting so I got in six
did they open the doors at six and let
you in then it was too yes I was but
with honesty after 15 minutes I got
thrown away you got what I got thrown
out of the house you got thrown out so
instead I got to the line for the
invitational Nintendo the tournament so
here's the band oh nice what are you
going to play it Nintendo I mean it's
not playing itself I get to watch the
pros good place so yeah it's 3,000
people gets to watch it and if those who
have VIP or yeah cosplay peers can get
closer to the closer seats to the whole
thing so you come to e3 do you know how
many years about you've been coming to e
three four years this is the most I more
do I never know because I never have no
faith and you're looking most forward to
seeing Nintendo here of course it's
smash vs playable so that's what my goal
is first goal first goal is to go to
nintendo is there anything else that you
want to see oh this everything is is
playable so you just have to catch my
interest to it you know coming to e3
that early 5am or six am being the first
person in line three years in a row you
probably are kind of an expert at e3 if
somebody's here for their first time
what advice would you give them to
really enjoy this on on expert mode like
you do
well it not don't be like me and be
alone have friends with you all right
well if you're watching come hang out
with Eric he knows how to do III right
thank you so much have a great time is
thank you